ETHAN ZOU: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to "Talks at Google."
My name is Ethan Zou.
I'm a member of the
engineering staffing team
here in New York City.
So in celebration of Asian
American Pacific Islander
Heritage Month, the
Asian Google Network
has partnered with
"Talks at Google"
to invite Christina Seid who is
the owner of the Chinatown Ice
Cream Factory.
So for those of you who are not
familiar with the Chinatown Ice
Cream Factory, it is, you
guessed it, an ice cream shop.
It's been in New York
for quite some time.
And it's also one of the
landmarks in Chinatown.
They serve some of the most
unique and authentic flavors
in New York City.
It's been featured in
publications like the Times
Magazine, the New York Times,
as well as our very own Zagat.
So just a little
bit about Christina.
So now she is the owner of the
factory, the ice cream shop.
And in addition to
her responsibility
in running the store and the
daily operations and planning,
she is also a mother, a blogger.
And she's also a very active
leader in the broader New York
City community.
She serves on the advisory
board and committees
for many nonprofit organizations
like Asian Women in Business,
Chinatown Youth Initiative, as
well as the coalition of Asian
Pacific Americans.
So without further
ado, I would love
to welcome Christina to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTINA SEID:
Thank you, Ethan,
for that great introduction.
ETHAN ZOU: Yeah, awesome.
It's so nice to have
you here with us today.
CHRISTINA SEID: I love Google.
It's your food.
ETHAN ZOU: Yeah.
The food here is
really, really good.
And Google definitely takes
care of its employees.
About your store, I actually
noticed that it's been around
for quite some time, right?
CHRISTINA SEID: Yeah.
We're going on 39
years this year.
ETHAN ZOU: 39 years.
Wow.
That is impressive.
So can you just share
a little bit more
with us about the
history and what
you've seen the store going
through over these years?
CHRISTINA SEID: Well, my father
actually started the store
when he was a little shy of 30.
In the same location,
originally, it
was a failed business-- a little
bit like a Panera or a Cozy.
It was much more before
its time in Chinatown.
So it eventually
went out of business.
But in the late '70s, that's
when Haagen-Dazs, Carvel,
Ben & Jerry's-- where ice
cream was getting really hot.
And that was the "in" thing.
So my father wanted
to bring something
that was trendy, but more
for the neighborhood people
with more of a Asian palate.
ETHAN ZOU: Yeah-- because I
was actually over at your store
not long ago.
And I noticed that you guys
have some very exotic flavors
like-- well, actually in
the store on the menu,
it says the original
flavors are like
lychee, mango, almond cookie.
CHRISTINA SEID: The
regular flavors.
It's supposed to be a joke.
People are like, that
doesn't make sense.
It's supposed to be
what's regular to us
is the lychee, the
red bean, the mango.
And the exotic is the vanilla.
That's what the tourists get.
ETHAN ZOU: What do you love
about owning this ice cream
shop?
CHRISTINA SEID: I
actually co-own it
with my father, who's still
around and very active--
knock on wood.
He's 67.
So I think it brings
him a lot of joy
to see that I'm
running it with him.
And it's been so successful.
Now, it's very "in" to
be in the food business.
But back then, it was more like
a middle class or-- especially
in Chinatown, there
was no young people
who did restaurant work--
this was before Food TV.
It was more considered
like menial labor.
So people with college
degrees didn't really
do that type of work.
My dad was actually
college educated.
But he has the entrepreneurial
spirit for sure.
ETHAN ZOU: Yeah, definitely.
What inspired you to join
in this business with them?
CHRISTINA SEID: I don't know
if it was like-- it wasn't just
that one day I decided I'm
just going to join my dad.
I've been working there
ever since I was 12 when
I was strong enough to work.
And back then, we didn't
have many employees.
And people asked me, oh,
your store is so busy.
You had it so many years.
Why don't you retire?
But we didn't make
money for many areas.
New York wasn't what it was.
Chinatown definitely wasn't
what it was-- what it is now.
But as I grew older,
the store got busier.
So my ambitions were always
catered around the store.
When I went away
to college, my dad
was forced to hire more
employees because he's like,
oh, she has to college.
But you have to
come home summers.
And you have to
come home holidays.
You can't go away because
you got to work the store.
But as I got older, it
got busier and busier.
So it just made sense for me to
go into a teaching profession
because I love children.
But also, you have
the summers off,
and you have weekends
off, and nights off.
And that's when
we're busy, right?
So it seems logical.
So when I was teaching, I was
also working at the store.
But then it just became too
much where I'm just like,
I either have two jobs
or I have one job.
And I just need to
focus on just having
one job because the work
life balance is just not
happening for me.
So that's how it became.
ETHAN ZOU: So you were
actually a teacher once.
CHRISTINA SEID: I mean-- still
very active with children.
I wrote a children's book.
I'm on the advisory board
for the Children's Museum
of the Arts.
I do different things.
I work with the kids
in the neighborhood
depending on what's going on.
But I don't think
I need to make it
my full-time job because
my full-time job--
obviously, the store.
ETHAN ZOU: Absolutely.
So you mentioned that
when you were younger,
you were working the
store with your father
and that Chinatown was actually
much more different back then.
What was it like, I guess,
working in Chinatown when
you were 12?
CHRISTINA SEID: I
really hated it.
I really, really hated it.
When my mom and dad got married,
people asked all the time
if I live in Chinatown.
All my friends are in
Chinatown because I
have to work in Chinatown.
Basically, my mom
made my dad move out
when they got married
to a suburb in Queens
called Little Neck.
That's where I wanted to do
my Saturday morning cartoons
and play sports.
That's what kids want
to do on the weekends.
They don't want to be
dragged to Chinatown.
I had a bag of fortune cookies
we had to like-- bag candy.
Back then, our store used to
be more like half ice cream
store and half a candy shop.
So that's where I started off.
Nobody wants to scoop ice
cream and mop the floors.
This is not what you picture.
And this is called family help.
This is not real help.
So my dad gave me
$30 for 15 hours.
That wasn't a good
deal back then
when I was 12, either,
letting you know.
It was not a good deal.
Of course, I hated it.
But my father
always said, if you
don't like doing
this type of work,
you have to study
hard in school.
But then, when you work Saturday
and Sunday for 15 hours,
you don't feel that
ambitious about school
because you don't
have energy to study.
But I used to feel very angry at
my dad in the back of my mind.
But then at the same
time, I was more
understanding because I
know my father wouldn't
make me go to work unless
he needed the help.
But we weren't making
much money back then,
so it's just logical.
ETHAN ZOU: And you
actually did both, right?
You worked and
you went to school
completing your master's degree?
CHRISTINA SEID: Yeah.
I did.
ETHAN ZOU: That's
quite incredible.
And when did you join
in on the ownership?
CHRISTINA SEID: I think
it was like a little bit
after my master's degree.
But even after my
master's degree,
I still finished a PhD
certificate at ICE.
And then I also went
to French Culinary
when it was called French
Culinary for a little bit.
I think learning doesn't
stop when you just
finish a master's or
finish whatever degree.
When you're learning, you have
to constantly be learning,
whether it's Google
Talks or whatnot.
ETHAN ZOU: Reflecting
on your journey
as the co-owner of this
ice cream shop, what
were some of the
things that you learned
and what was it like when
you initially took over
the business-- and
also your journey
from taking over to what
it is essentially, now,
today, super famous--
line out the door.
What was that like for you?
CHRISTINA SEID: I
think it's very cool
that being an-- they called
it being an entrepreneur.
When I did it,
nobody was doing it.
So a lot of my
classmates from college
would say, oh, is it
because you can't get a job.
Or is it like, why are you
working for your parents?
Nobody was doing food
business at that time--
because I'm dating
myself a little.
But this is like-- I'm
a child of the '80s.
So that's when Citigroup,
all the big corporations--
everybody wants to be a banker.
Everybody wanted
to be corporate.
But then, you see this
change in the shift
where everybody starts to
want to become their own boss.
All these lawyers
want to quit their job
and have a food truck.
And the Food TV
makes it [INAUDIBLE].
So now, it's like, oh,
you're an entrepreneur.
You're a star.
And I'm like, oh.
I thought I just mopped floors.
This is very cool for me.
I won my first award.
And Abigail Disney--
she gave me an award.
And part of my speech was
this is the only award
that I've ever won in my life.
I've always been
mediocre in school.
This is so amazing.
I think that from being a
shopkeeper that you could still
stick at something and you can
make it something great, which
is fantastic.
ETHAN ZOU: Yeah, absolutely.
And I think when people
see success, what they see
is on the outside, which is,
oh, this is so glamorous.
You're making so much money.
The shop is doing so well.
But rarely, do they think
about the hard work that
goes into the shop.
So thinking back
on your journey,
was there anything in
particular that was really
difficult and challenging.
And how did you overcome
those challenges?
CHRISTINA SEID: I don't know
if it was just me personally.
But I think-- I don't
know how many of you
guys are New Yorkers or have
been in Chinatown in the '80s
or '70s or even '90s.
The gangs were a very
big problem for us.
But I think it's a
problem for everybody.
When my family stood up to
the gangs, it was a big deal.
People back then--
the Chinese people,
when they get their gold
for their weddings--
the gangs were so crazy that
they used to go to the weddings
and they just used to
rob and just take gold.
And extortion was huge.
A lot of violence.
Caused a lot of disharmony
in my family actually.
My mother wanted my father
to sell the business.
Actually, I wanted my
father to sell the business
because, if you think your dad's
going to get killed, of course,
you want dad to
sell the business.
But it was against
his principles.
And at that time, we also
weren't making money.
It's one thing if
you get extorted
and you're making
a lot of money.
But you're not
making money, why do
you want to keep the business?
But it was something that my
dad believed in, that he built.
But I think as a family, as a
whole, it was very hard for us.
And then sometimes,
my dad's victorious.
But some days, you're dad's not
victorious and gets beat up.
But I think I learned a lot
from that because you just
can't run from things.
You just have to persevere.
And I think after
that, slowly it
started cleaning up
after a series of not so
happy fights between my
dad and the gang kids.
And there was one instance
where he stabbed one of them.
And that was-- well, a
series of many things.
But after a while, they
just-- it's kind of like being
bullied.
It doesn't stop when
you're in school.
It happens when you grow up.
But after a series of
incidents, they just
started extorting
other people, not us.
And slowly, New York
has been cleaned up.
So luckily, everything after
that seems kind of like cake.
So that's really like real.
ETHAN ZOU: What was that
like for you having gangs
coming to extort you and
then building up to the point
where that incident happened?
CHRISTINA SEID: Well,
I feel fortunate.
When I was about 12,
when I started working.
It was bad, but they
laid off us a little bit.
Because I'm a girl
and I was young,
when they try to cluster
in front of your store
to scare people away from
doing business with you
or they try to
intimidate you, it's
better that I talk to them
instead of my dad, I found,
because they could get
into more confrontations.
So I try to use the girl
factor-- I'm a kid factor.
It's like, oh guys,
sorry, I think
you're blocking my doorway.
Usually they just
feel bad for me.
So they go somewhere else.
But sometimes when they get
into things with my dad,
it's not that cool.
ETHAN ZOU: That must
be quite challenging.
I mean, at the time, I can only
imagine what that looks like.
CHRISTINA SEID: It used to
be so bad that-- I remember
we used to park our car
so far by the Brooklyn
Bridge on Delancey Street.
I don't even know if that's
the name of the bridge.
It's so bad.
But by Delancey Street.
And we have to
walk to Chinatown.
And when we used
to take my sister.
I remember my dad used to carry
a gun under the baby carriage.
This is Chinatown in
the '80s and '90s.
It just was not that great.
As a shopkeeper, it
just was very rough.
ETHAN ZOU: Well, I'm really
glad that New York is not
like that anymore.
CHRISTINA SEID: But
I feel extremely safe
now in Chinatown.
People are like, how do
you walk home at 4:00
in the morning from your shop.
I was like, dude,
this is so safe.
ETHAN ZOU: I mean, it's
really hard to imagine.
I go there all the time.
CHRISTINA SEID: It's
super safe, now.
ETHAN ZOU: It's super safe.
So I guess, now, that
the city is much safer--
and also going
back to the growth
that your store has seen, that
your community has experienced.
How were you able to, I
guess, take the business
and really grow it building
up to what it is today?
CHRISTINA SEID: I
see other families
where the second generation
tries to take over.
And it's not such a
happy transition as well.
I think because my dad
and I have worked together
for so long, we have
a real understanding
of where we fit with each other.
I think my dad knows
where his place is.
And I know where my place is.
I think we have a common
goal to grow the business.
And we really know the business
because I'm there all the time.
You asked me earlier, do you
actually work at the store?
I was like, yes, I'm like
seven months pregnant.
And I'm still moving
ice cream and scooping.
One of my employees-- she
looked at me and she says,
how do you even move?
How do you even scoop ice cream?
Doesn't your stomach
get in the way?
I'm like, yeah, it does.
But I still do it.
I think physically being there,
understanding your customers'
needs, what people want.
They want durian ice cream.
And I mean, that was our
most requested flavor.
And we were like
hedging away from it.
For those of you that
don't know what durian is,
it's very stinky.
It has its own preparation.
We have to treat everything
separately with durian.
But just being there and knowing
what your customer wants,
how they feel, how
your employees feel-- I
think that's all been
really helpful with growing
the business.
ETHAN ZOU: Absolutely.
So interesting that you
mentioned the durian ice cream.
So I was really
curious, so what were
some of the
inspirations behind some
of these very exotic flavors?
CHRISTINA SEID: Do you want to
know about the durian or just
in general?
ETHAN ZOU: Well, I'd love to
hear more about the durian.
But I'd also love to
hear about them all.
CHRISTINA SEID:
The durian is-- we
have a lot of Southeast
Asian customers
and a lot of Chinese customers.
And they all love durian.
It's either you really love
it or you really hate it.
It's like stinky tofu.
But we were just
hedging away from it.
We don't want to touch durian.
It's going to stink.
But then, eventually we made it.
And we got used to
the preparation.
My husband's Filipino.
So if you know any Filipino
people, what they love to do
is that-- it's
been a huge seller.
I never understood why
[? Maylaiwa, ?] the roast pork
place across the way that
was like so popular--
but they don't just buy one
quart of durian for themself.
They're like-- oh, my
sister would love durian
and my cousin loves durian.
So I'm going to buy like
10 quarts of durian.
So this has been a huge seller
for us for the southeast
Asian population because
it's something that they love
but that they want to share
it with their family as well.
So that's been fantastic
for us-- the durian.
ETHAN ZOU: Do you
see lot of, I guess,
non-Southeast Asians trying
out the durian flavor?
CHRISTINA SEID: Yeah.
People, when they think that
we have exotic ice cream--
we do have exotic ice
cream in the sense
that we try to make new flavors.
But whatever flavor
we decide on,
we have to make sure that--
even if you hate durian,
that it tastes really
good-- that you still
would find it palatable.
Andrew Zimmermann
from Food TV-- he
always talks about
how he hates durian.
And he says, oh, I hate durian.
It's the worst thing ever.
But then he eats
crabs from the sewer.
The name of the show
is "Bizarre Foods."
Durian is not that
bad compared to eating
like lamb brains or something.
So when he came and he
tried our ice cream.
And he's like, well, actually,
your durian ice cream
is like-- I hate durian,
but the durian ice
cream is pretty good.
And that was a sign of a
true chef-- making something
that someone doesn't like and
making it palatable for them.
ETHAN ZOU: Wow.
That's very cool.
CHRISTINA SEID: So that's
made me really happy.
I was like straight on.
ETHAN ZOU: So
perhaps, the next time
you're in the neighborhood, you
should definitely try a scoop.
Also very curious on
the flavor pairing.
Do you have any recommendation
in terms of maybe pairing
two different flavors or
the combination of a few
has yielded a interesting
or a good pairing?
CHRISTINA SEID: Well,
our signature cakes
are the lychee red bean mango
cakes or a variation of that.
Lychee, read bean, and
mango, or lychee, red bean,
and green tea.
We just do a tremendous
volume on our cakes.
And actually, most of the
people who buy our cakes
are not from Chinatown.
They bring it to Jersey.
They bring it to Queens.
And for any of you guys who live
a little bit outside the city.
It's kind of cumbersome to
carry something so heavy.
And it's perishable.
But people-- we sell hundreds
of cakes a day for a small shop.
And that's a lot.
That's a lot.
About 80% to 90% of our cakes
are the same combination,
even if people could select
their own flavors, which
is pretty interesting.
You just think that, oh, if
you just make one flavor off
that people would
like that cake.
But that combination seems
like it's the winner.
ETHAN ZOU: That sounds
really interesting.
I could talk about ice
cream and cake all day.
But I'd love to
switch the subject
and hear a little bit about your
involvement in the community.
What's been your
inspiration to serve
on all of these nonprofits
and advisory boards on top
of your work at the store?
CHRISTINA SEID: I think
it's our obligation
to give back to the community.
I think I've been less
active because I'm a mom
and I'm pregnant, so
obviously my energy is less.
But I think it also
breaks up your day.
And it makes you a
better person in general.
The other day, I just got
so wrapped up in my work.
And I'm like, oh,
man, it's so busy.
And we all have those moments.
We're like, shit,
we're having a bad day.
Sorry, I said that aloud.
Or like, oh, I need to
get a drink or something.
And then you look
at your belly--
like, I can't have a drink.
But then I was
checking my emails.
And then I got an email saying
that the elementary school down
the block was
doing a fundraiser.
We're very active with
the elementary school.
They helped to redesign
our storefront.
I work with some of the kids.
And they said that they're
having a fund raiser.
So then they were
asking if they could
have some gift certificates
because they're
doing this raffle.
And this other organization
asked me to go to their gala.
But I couldn't make it.
And I said, oh, would you like
this for the silent auction--
just to be part of
that and to remember
that there are different
causes and involvement.
I can't be as involved
physically serving on boards.
But I could maybe help
through ice cream,
or charitable donations,
or whether it be advice,
or whatnot, or coming to talks.
I've done a lot of talks
on during APA month.
My calendar's pretty packed
with events during APA month.
ETHAN ZOU: We're very
glad to have you here.
What would you say was your
most memorable experience
from serving in the community?
CHRISTINA SEID: Most memorable.
That's a hard one.
That wasn't on your list.
ETHAN ZOU: Throwing
you a curve ball there.
CHRISTINA SEID: Most
memorable-- This is actually
one I haven't gotten before.
ETHAN ZOU: That's OK.
We can come back to
that later perhaps.
CHRISTINA SEID: Yeah.
We can come back that one.
ETHAN ZOU: So obviously,
you've seen a lot
of changes in the community.
I'm going back to what you
were saying about how you've
seen the Chinatown change.
And how the whole city has
gotten rid of the crime.
Where do you think are
some of the biggest
challenges that the community
is facing now and specifically
within the API community?
CHRISTINA SEID: API
community or Chinatown?
ETHAN ZOU: Or broader.
CHRISTINA SEID: I think we're
increasing in our population,
obviously, in New York
City, which is great.
I think we're doing a
pretty good job overall
with growing different
organizations, and whatnot,
and getting involved, and
creating affinity groups.
But I think that
some help-- that
might help from
the corporate side
would be maybe some
more matching programs--
corporate matching-- some
more support on their side.
But I think it's kind
of a broad question.
Yeah, sorry.
I think voting is pretty big.
I think the vote-- people
need to be more involved
with voting-- the Asian
population for sure.
People need to recognize that--
will recognize a lot more
of our needs if we vote more.
Doesn't matter who you vote for,
it just matters that you vote.
ETHAN ZOU: Absolutely.
I think that's really important
given that New York City has
really seen an increase in
Asian American population,
as well with the big
election coming up.
CHRISTINA SEID:
Nobody in my family
eats until everybody votes,
even local elections.
It's very important.
It doesn't matter
who you vote for.
We need to be recognized
as a voting bloc.
ETHAN ZOU: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
So just in a few minutes, we'll
open up the floor for Q&A.
So if you have some
questions that you
would like to ask
Christina, you can
feel free to go ahead and
line up at the mic now.
So going back to the ice cream
because I love it so much.
Can you tell us more
about the process
and then the work
that really goes
into making this ice cream?
Do you guys make it in-house
or is it outsourced?
CHRISTINA SEID: They
actually make everything
on premises, which is pretty
impressive considering
we only have 550
square feet on top
and 550 for production space.
And we have a huge volume.
Each ice cream flavor has
a different preparation.
So I think that's
fantastic because it's just
kind of proprietary.
It's just me and my dad
that prep everything.
But I think a lot of it
comes from also inspiration.
Zen butter is one of
our more popular flavors
where it may be like
you wanted to go back
to like knowing where
the inspiration came from
or-- zen butter is actually
not something that's
Chinese in the sense
like-- people think,
oh, it's like zen, like z-e-n.
And then butter.
So it's actually peanut butter
ice cream with sesame seeds.
So I grew up with this
guy when I was younger.
And he always used to bug
me to make a peanut butter
flavor for him.
And I can't just make a
peanut butter flavor for you
because it doesn't fit
in line with our brand.
So his name was Chris
Tzen, with T-z-e-n.
And then one day I
was eating at what's
[? Xi'an ?] Foods, right now.
But it used to be a
restaurant owned by my friend.
And she used to make
peanut butter noodles
with sesame seeds, which is
a [? cold ?] peanut butter
and sesame seed noodles.
ETHAN ZOU: So good.
CHRISTINA SEID: So it's
like more Shanghai dish.
So I was eating.
And I was like all, oh, this
is really cold and delicious.
It's peanut butter
and sesame seeds.
So in his honor, I decided to
create the name zen butter.
But instead of a
t-z-e-n, it's z-e-n.
So people think it's like
this like-- so that's
one of the inspirations.
But whenever I eat
something, I get inspired.
So I eat lot of
different things.
I think a lot of
entrepreneurs-- sometimes
they just get so wrapped
up in their business,
they only eat their own food.
I like to try everybody's food.
ETHAN ZOU: And also you're
in a good place to try--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CHRISTINA SEID: Yeah,
it's New York City.
ETHAN ZOU: It's perfect.
CHRISTINA SEID: I love
eating out, experiencing
different things.
ETHAN ZOU: That's
also good to know
that, I guess, for
your inspiration,
you just pick it up from
the smallest things in life.
And I guess, I'm also
hearing a little bit,
if I bug you enough, you'll
make another flavor in my name.
CHRISTINA SEID: Maybe.
Maybe.
ETHAN ZOU: Very cool.
So at this point, any
questions from the audience?
Oh, hey.
AUDIENCE: So maybe we'll
see the next ice cream
flavor will be the Ethan.
So thanks for coming in.
It's really exciting to
hear from you, especially
from a local perspective.
And I think everybody
loves ice cream.
So thank you so much for
also kindly bringing it
all for us to try.
My question is more
for entrepreneurs.
You mentioned there's a
lot of people like-- food,
and food shops, food trucks.
That's like the
thing now, right?
And I see, especially in
the LES and Chinatown,
a lot of new places coming up.
What would you say in terms of
what would your best advice be
for budding entrepreneurs
in the food space,
especially here
in New York City?
CHRISTINA SEID: I think it's
important to make whatever
food that you're designing for
your business not too faddish.
I feel like New York City
is like the land of fads.
It's this fad or that fad.
I think when my father
started the Ice Cream Factory,
he was really
innovative for his time.
Back then, nobody
was flavoring food.
This is like the late 70s.
Nobody had green tea ice cream.
People didn't even know
what green tea was.
This is before Snapple
made green tea cool.
Now, green tea-- you
can have it anywhere.
People would ask,
what's green tea?
Now everything's so faddish.
You see on BuzzFeed, oh,
that they have a rainbow this
or like-- I just think that's
fads-- they come and go.
People will line
up for like a day.
These pop ups-- they come
all the time, which is great.
Pop ups are great.
And I've attended them.
But I don't know if it's
enough to be a main business.
So I think that when you make
your food in New York City,
you have to make it something
that people will just generally
love and that they'll come back
for more, not something that's
just a one stop shop.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
CHRISTINA SEID: Thanks, Ashley.
AUDIENCE: My name's Carlin.
Thanks for coming.
This is great.
I wanted to ask, on a
lighter note, what's
your favorite ice cream flavor?
And do you eat a lot
of your own ice cream?
CHRISTINA SEID:
I love ice cream.
I'm an almond cookie girl.
Almond cookie is
my favorite flavor.
I do eat a lot of it.
The only ice cream I
have left in my house
is mint chip because
that's the one
thing my husband doesn't eat.
He eats everything
else in the freezer.
My daughter is three, now.
But she's been eating ice cream
since she was six months old.
I know some people
had issues with this
because you're not supposed
to start whole milk
til you're one.
But she's never gotten
sick and she's three.
So I attributed to that all--
the ice cream is healthy.
Eat more ice cream.
You'll have a happy life
and healthy children.
ETHAN ZOU: That's how I
feel or my justification
when I finish a whole tub.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
for coming again.
Quick question.
You mentioned green tea.
It's everywhere like
this matcha flavors.
Everything.
What do you think is
the next big thing in--
CHRISTINA SEID:
The next big thing?
I feel like in New York,
everything has kind of been
done, which is a little
bit bad because, now-- I
had this flavor that was
like strawberry rhubarb--
no, strawberry balsamic.
And everyone's like raving
about it like, this is the best.
It's strawberry balsamic.
I was like, you cannot clearly
tell me you taste anything
balsamic in it.
They just add the word
balsamic and everybody's
raving about it.
So I think that-- like
what Ashley's question
about not making food
palatable for entrepreneurs.
You have to make
something that's good.
It's not just trendy.
Oh, it's balsamic.
Because it's just
strawberry ice cream.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
CHRISTINA SEID: No problem.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I'm probably of a
slightly younger generation.
So it was kind of crazy hearing
you talk about Chinatown
back in the day.
I'm curious to know from the
perspective of the Ice Cream
Factory, how has it evolved
as Chinatown evolved.
CHRISTINA SEID: I
think right now, it's
kind of cool to see-- whenever
you see like a grandma
or like a papa or something,
you always just think,
oh, she's going to
get lychee ice cream.
But now, you see them,
like, oh, I want rocky road
or I want red velvet.
So I think my father always used
to say that food is the best
introduction to culture.
So back then, if
somebody ate lychee,
you would feel like, oh, I
introduced them to lychee.
But now, you're seeing
the reverse culture
where you're seeing people
who are real neighborhood
people trying more American
flavors or things that they
might not try outside
the neighborhood
because they feel
comfortable with us.
So that's been pretty cool.
The neighborhood has changed a
lot in the sense-- or New York
has changed a lot.
When I took over my
family's business--
there was no young
people in Chinatown.
Now, a lot of the
businesses are starting
to be owned by young people,
which is pretty cool.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ETHAN ZOU: Cool.
This gentlemen--
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
I'm a big fan since 1990,
I think, of your store.
CHRISTINA SEID: Yay.
AUDIENCE: So with the
success of the store,
I'm wondering if
you feel pressure
to open other locations
like many business.
CHRISTINA SEID: I knew
this question was coming.
AUDIENCE: And why do you--
CHRISTINA SEID:
--which is awesome.
I get requests for
this all the time.
A lot of people want
to buy franchises.
Or they want to
partner or whatnot.
In my 20s, I felt very
pressured to feel like, oh,
where's the right space
or when's the right time.
I think it just doesn't feel
organic to me, right now.
People think that if you
just have more stores,
you make more money or that
it's a growing business.
It's growing in the sense
you have two stores.
But for me, I think
I really don't
want the quality to go down.
And some things are
not about money.
It's just that I
really want to maintain
the integrity of the store
that my father built.
And not right now.
I think if it felt very organic
and everything was right.
But I'm not going to open
one just because-- just
to open-- like Flushing
is the big neighborhood.
Everyone's like, why don't
you have one in Flushing?
I was like, it just
doesn't feel right.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Christina.
Thanks for coming to Google.
As Ethan said, the Google
food is really good.
But we don't really
have ice cream.
So you mentioned--
CHRISTINA SEID: Gotta
work on this, man.
AUDIENCE: --your ice cream
make employee happier--
improve working efficiency.
Do you see any possibilities
like [INAUDIBLE] in the future.
CHRISTINA SEID: I
think there should
be a study done on that-- maybe
equating efficiency with ice
cream eating, possibly.
Yeah.
ETHAN ZOU: That's awesome.
I also--
AUDIENCE: --happy to test that.
CHRISTINA SEID: So
what's your flavor?
Have you been to the Ice
Cream Factory before?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
The green tea.
CHRISTINA SEID: The
green tea's your flavor?
Yeah. green tea's pretty solid.
ETHAN ZOU: I also hope that
our kitchen staff is here, too,
so they heard this question.
We also happen to have some
flavors in ice cream here
today.
Thanks to Christina
for bringing it over.
[APPLAUSE]
So today, we have
green tea, lychee,
and, your favorite,
almond cookies.
CHRISTINA SEID: Oh, yes.
That's great.
ETHAN ZOU: Yeah.
So thank you
everybody for coming.
And thank you, Christina, for
our being a gracious guest.
CHRISTINA SEID: Thank
you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]
ETHAN ZOU: I hope everybody
can stay for a few minutes,
maybe go with us, hang out,
and have some ice cream.
Thank you.